let's consider the motion of a wheel
that's rolling along the ground with
some center of mass velocity BC M and
because the wheel is rotating it has an
angular velocity and you can see that
that vector is directed into the plane
of the board now
what we like to do is consider the
kinetic energy of this continuous body a
little bit later on that body has moved
some distance and what we want to
consider is the fact that not only is
every point in the body moving with the
center of mass speed but there's this
additional rotational energy that's
associated with the fact that every
point in the center of mass reference
frame is undergoing circular motion so
how do we describe that well we'll do
that by choosing some point in the body
so let's pick a point we'll call that MJ
with mass M J and the velocity of this
point remember has two components to
simplify it will give itself a little
more picture here the point has every
single point in the object has the V cm
but because this object is undergoing
circular motion there is VCM J that's
the rotational circular tangential
velocity and so the vector sum of these
two is the actual velocity BJ of the
jate object BJ is equal to the center of
mass velocity plus the tangential
rotational velocity that it has because
it's undergoing circular motion and now
what we'd like to do is calculate the
kinetic energy of this object
well the kinetic energy is the sum J
from 1 to N of 1/2 M J times the
velocity of this J particle squared
which we can take as a dot product so we
can write that as VC
plus v CM j dot v CM plus the CM j and
that's just VJ squared so when we look
at these terms it looks complicated at
first but there's some nice there's
going to be v CM v CM there's 2 cross
terms they're identical and vc m jb c MJ
so let's write out those three terms we
have 1/2 m j vc m dot v cm is v cm
squared now every point in the object
has the same v CM so we can pull that
one out of the sum and now we have we'll
take these cross terms so we have the
sum over j from 1 to n there's two cross
terms so the two of those are going to
cancel and inside here we have the we
have to remember to keep our mass
element that's important now i'm going
to write it as MJ b c MJ vector now
remember when you dot with v CM every
single point has the same bc m every j
element has the same be end so i can
pull that bc m outside and finally I
have the last term which is the sum over
j from 1 to n of 1/2 MJ b CM j squared
and that's just the dot product of those
two terms and so our kinetic energy
looks rather complicated but let's focus
on this term right here because recall
from our video on the center of mass
that the definition of the center of
mass reference frame so if you're moving
in the center of mass that in the center
of mass reference frame the sum of MJ v
CM j is equal to 0
so for instance if you're in the
center-of-mass frame you're moving with
VCM the only velocity is this and in
that frame the sum of MJ v c MJ is zero
and we did a video on that one before
and that's exactly what's in this term
so this term is 0 so this remember was
how we defined the center of mass
reference right and therefore our
kinetic energy consists of two pieces
this first piece is just 1/2 the total
mass times V cm squared and our second
piece over here we'll just write it out
now 1/2 sum over j MJ the CM J squared
now if you were moving with the center
of mass then this J object is just
undergoing circular motion and so we
have our result that we've used many
times is that the velocity the
tangential rotational velocity is just
equal to the radius our s J's so let's
introduce that our s J times the angular
speed Omega and when we put that into
this term we see our kinetic energy has
two pieces M total V center of mass
squared plus one-half J goes from 1 to n
I didn't finish that sum there
MJ our s J squared now just remember
that every single point in the object
has the same angular speed and so we can
pull out the Omega squared in there and
in the because this is a continuous body
and we take the limit as we
before as MJ goes to 0 this quantity of
mass times distance squared is just the
moment of inertia about the center of
mass of that body and in conclusion K is
one-half M total the center of mass
squared plus one-half the moment of
inertia about the center of mass times
the angular speed squared now this is
the same crucial decomposition that
we've talked about many times this first
piece is what we call the translational
kinetic energy because it just
represents how the center of mass of the
is moving and the second piece is what
we call the rotational kinetic energy
because it's a representation of just
the kinetic energy of rotation for
example if you were in the center of
mass frame there would be no
translational energy and this would be
the only kinetic energy